hey everybody how are we all doing
tonight
pretty well I hope looks like are we
running decently looks like it's down a
little bit first few seconds always
taking up with me adjusting the camera
yeah this this shirt actually was sent
to the PIO box by a Middleton who is my
guest for the non-binary conversation so
thank you em they have they have a great
sense of humor
amongst being very smart and easy to
talk to and listen to ID seriously I
could listen to them talk to like for
forever
uh-oh
thanks disassociation nation very sweet
of you I'm inspired yeah I know it's
that's just fun to say isn't it what do
you have to drink there oh this water as
usual the one thing that I have with
this is that sometimes it actually is
just water not always but sometimes I
like to keep people on their toes also
gives me on my toes
that shirt reminded me of em not
surprises from them what well spotted
thank heroin good evening I got some
Slytherin PJs at Hot Topic earlier today
whoo nice I actually just got out of my
slithering gear cuz I just I just
finished shooting the review for order
of the Phoenix so I just barely stripped
out of my Slytherin stuff
so that's uh as me being productive I'm
actually like I'm for my evening I'm
actually where I want to be for once
like I already shot my my video that I
wanted to get shot today and did the
editing that I wanted to do so once I'm
done here I can actually didn't like go
to bed which is crazy just stop anybody
say hi I'll thanks Steven well nice to
see ya I hope you're over your cold more
or less and if you're not I hope you
recover soon let's see are you going to
rank or re-rank the Potter films at the
end of your marathon well it's not gonna
be a rear ank it's gonna be an initial
right cuz I haven't ranked those I'm
pretty sure I haven't so yeah it's gonna
be initial one the here's the big
question right now hanging over over
that potential video well I say
potential that's gonna happen that's
gonna cap off the the entire revisit so
the question is whether or not I include
the fantastic beasts movies now I'm
doing them as part of the reward
so I'll review them or re review them in
those cases to see if I feel any
different from my reviews that are
already on the record for those but
whether or not I'll include them in the
ranking is it gonna come down to whether
or not they would just occupy the bottom
two spots in which case I'll just
acknowledge at the front end look the
bottom two spots are those movies let's
move on from there because it's not
worth spending time on them after that
as far as I'm concerned but if one or
more of them or both of them not likely
if the first one manages to nudge its
way as being better than any of the main
series films for me okay then maybe I'll
include them but well we will end up
seeing Slytherin in the house do you
ever get annoyed that the fourth movie
on got so dark it's hard to see in
daylight um annoyed no cuz I never I
personally ever thought I got that bad
but I actually I did
mention that number five kind of marks
the the distinct darkening visual of it
there's some of that in the fourth one
but it's not across the whole movie it's
just certain scenes I'm starting the
fifth movie it's yeah it's pretty much
the whole movie and actually a little
bit in the third as well not quite as
much as it happened when David started
directing but honestly the third one had
a much more muted color palette that I
remembered not Batman vs Superman dark
thankfully that jeez hah that thing you
know one of these days I've been talking
about doing it forever and I suppose
this this'll be as good a lead in into
the theoretical topic of this live
stream as any one of the things I've had
on the to do list for a while is I have
a couple of friends who have not seen
Batman V Superman and I want to sit down
with them and the extended version which
I haven't seen because I only saw the
theatrical and record us watching it and
put together a highlight reel of them
sorry through the movie so that's one of
those things like with no date I'd like
I want to do that eventually but when
I'll get to it I don't know cuz when I
whenever I actually shoot that it's
gonna be a big pain to actually cut
together just finished reading the
Prisoner of Azkaban I but I've almost
finished I actually got one chapter to
go I have I have been reading the first
one Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's
Stone because it got the American
version of the book I've been reading
that to my daughter that has been her
nightly bedtime story
and she's digging it which I'm very
happy to see be the case so i I've now
actually get effectively almost finished
rereading the first one which I hadn't
in a while
why would you want to put your friends
through that do you not like them oh no
I like them they're game for this
because they think you they think it'll
be hilarious they don't know the pain so
they just think it'll be fun
I'm a chapter four in the first book oh
cool
what about doing reviews and ranking up
the James Bond films the the issue there
is I haven't seen off James Bond films
and so before I could rank them I would
have to carve out enough time in my
schedule to watch the ones I haven't
seen which is I don't know like eight or
ten that I haven't seen so you know no I
just I just don't have the time if and
when I ever get around to seeing all of
them yeah sure I'll do a ranking just
like if it when I ever get around to
seeing all of classic who that I need to
I'll start incorporating that into into
dark truth ranking videos more than I
currently do here's the trick to make
that video shorter only mention the good
things in BBS so the the Arkham style
fight and
yeah I mean I'm honestly re watching out
I find more good in it than that cuz it
has been so long since I've seen the
dang thing oh you're just evil I
understand now yeah
see now you're getting it uh atomic
blonde was great uh the movie or the
book cuz the movie I had mixed feelings
about the movie I felt like the plot was
way too convoluted for its own good
especially given that what was good
about the movie in no way was made
better by the convoluted plot and
runtime cuz like the the visceral lot
that fight scene that that really
extended one where the people are just
exhausted by the end of it I love that
fight scene I don't think a lot of what
else is going on the movie does a lot
you know the really good stuff is the
visual the visceral action stuff and the
plot doesn't bolster that at all
jesse eisenberg question mark you're
funny
we've got part where Batman hits
Superman in the head with the sink is
good I mean not sure it's the moment to
be going for a visual joke but it's a
thing sure everyone here happy rocktober
is it just me or is October the the
month that gets the most tinkered with
like name wise like I have artist
friends who are engaging in inktober I
have writer friends who are gonna do nah
no Remo next month in are this is
they're prepped over now we got
rocktober
I like I feel like this happens talked
over more than other months and there's
probably something I'm missing on topic
anything Star Wars related coming out
before episode 9 comes out I don't have
anything planned I just I can't I can't
think of anything to talk about Star
Wars wise prior to that coming out
I mean I mean maybe the next trailer but
I guess the thing is I don't have a lot
of motivation to I don't know if you
heard that thunder I don't have a lot of
motivation to dig into Star Wars and I
don't just and I don't want people
thinking like oh it's just last Jedi
broke me I mean I didn't like the last
Jedi and that did take the wind out of
my sails for the movie a little bit but
the thing is my interest in Star Wars
has always just been the movies I've
never watched any of the shows I mean I
might check out the Mandalorian so like
maybe you'll get a video out of that
we'll see but right now I don't really
have anything planned I'm hoping to
tweet something witchy every day oh
that's a good that's a good goal how far
in advance do you plan videos um I have
I have a docket that I I have the full
month of October planned out to the
video like every video that I'm putting
out this month I know exactly what I
intend to do now that's not to say it
won't get moved around if stuff happens
or I have an idea that is topical and
can't wait to be stuck somewhere else
later and right now the docket extends
out into about June of next year now
that's not full there are some things
that I know at the pace that I'm doing
them I know will keep me going through
into June but that's not like I know
everything I'm doing in June I knew I
know about a quarter of what I'll be
doing in June so I try I try and plan in
advance I think try and shoot as much in
advance as I can I'm trying to get
better at that I had a buffer built up
but then I had you know vacations where
I was away and it burned through a lot
of my buffer so I'm in the process of
rebuilding that I feel that some of the
less PC critics being overly sensitive
to stuff like Rambo last blood what do
you think um I don't know because I've
neither seen Rambo less blood
and I've only like seen I think maybe
two reviews neither of which are critics
who I would consider to be particularly
PC and they didn't really like it either
I like I don't know see the thing is
like whenever people ask me a question
like that in the broad sense I'm almost
never gonna answer it because my answer
is usually it's a case-by-case basis
thing and the specific instance you're
asking me I don't have the information
because I haven't seen either the film
the question or the reviews so I don't
know like here here's the thing here's
what I'll say the thing with critics um
and this has become obfuscated by stuff
like Rotten Tomatoes we just started
putting emphasis on critical consensus I
don't look at Rotten Tomatoes anymore
the way I approach reviews and and film
critics is I find ones that I enjoy
their reviews not necessarily because I
always agree with them but because I
like their presentation and I think they
do a good job of explaining why they
feel what they do about it
and in my mind a critic who's good in
explaining what was good about it or
explaining what was bad about it they
they make you understand oh okay
not it's not just a straight I'll like
it because the critic liked it'll be oh
the critic liked it because this and
they feel this way about that thing I
don't feel that same way so even though
they liked it I probably won't or you
know they'll they didn't like this thing
like well this thing really bothers me
and go well that sort of thing doesn't
bother me maybe I'll link this movie
better I think it's important to have
critics that you know well enough that
you can gauge off of them so the whole
idea of critics being 2pc like in my
mind a critic is gonna bring their
perspective whatever it is I think the
whole the big problem with Rotten
Tomatoes is created this illusion that
criticism is somehow unanimous like
there's there's a PC critic things like
no some critics are more concerned about
that some are not if they're good about
the way they present their criticism you
understand whether or not that's part of
their perspective earthen or it isn't
and you can decide for yourself if you
think that means they had a different
reaction than you would again that's
saying good Craig's bad critics a lot of
Internet critics who just go who looks
bad or odds amazing but don't really
explain yeah that doesn't help either
do you watch Babylon 5 I have never seen
an episode of Babylon 5 I have a lot of
friends who are fans of it but I've
never seen Babylon 5 Adams lately I feel
slightly guilty about that cuz I used
Babylon 5 as a punchline way back near
the start of this channel when it was
originally scripted comedy shorts I feel
slightly bad about it but I still like
that punchline
even now so I guess I'm just a bad
person ah I've only seen last Jedi once
and didn't like it and I don't want to
see it again do you think i rewatch do
you think if i rewatch it i would like
you more
I don't know cuz I'm very Washington
either I just I just don't really want
to the thing is I find it's it's
surprising how few movies I watch a
second time these days again I think
talking up largely to a little free time
I really have you know I sit down to
watch some of these like well I can
either watch something that I have on
the docket that I need to make a video
for or I can watch something that I've
already watched one more time well guess
what usually happens but like even
beyond that element I don't really want
to watch last Jedi again I recently
found a YouTube video of home videos
from behind the scenes of the first
Harry Potter movie oh those could be fun
do you think the new Batman will be
comic accurate while giving us a story
we can follow I that to me is a messed
up question because comic accurate to
which version of Batman because it was
in comic accurate to how Batman is now I
have no idea I'm not reading curandera
Batman comics are you saying comic
accurate too
do 50 to Batman comic accurate to
post-crisis Batman comic I Kruger to
Killing Joke Batman Dark Knight Returns
Batman - it's a Silver Age Batman - the
death of the family era Batman like the
very question will it be comic I hear a
Batman is is a really weird one to me
because and that's not just restricted
to Batman let me be clear that's that's
true of the vast majority of especially
superhero comic adaptations these things
have been around so long and the
different eras are very very different
in terms of the way the characters are
presented and sometimes even behave I
think it's true of spider-man as well
that when you say oh it's comic accurate
I'm like - which era and I think
actually that's the case for Batman more
than most because I think he's gone
through a lot more drastic shifts and
characterization than a lot have but I'm
still waiting to find out more about
that I enjoy reviews less for the rating
than the presentation and conclusions
hence me being here oh wow you kind of
have to be here considering that I don't
actually use ratings so thoughts on
Disney planning to take over Russia and
start the dss now I kind of want to see
a shirtless Putin fighting Mickey Mouse
I don't I don't know why that that
tickled me so much
what was the Babylon 5 punch line I'd
mean tip I mean if you just go back to
the shorts it's I'll tell you what what
one it was give me a second because like
it I don't it's a joke in the context of
everything else that's going on in the
short so if I just tell you it's not
gonna function as a joke on its own if
it functions at all which I think is
possibly debatable
it functions within the context of the
you know of the overall peace so give me
a second and I will tell you what what
to find I mean I've got I've got a whole
section for for the shorts I've got I've
got a playlist for that there's a
playlist for that come on come on come
on come on
and now I'm stinking away more time and
day answering this question than I had
intended but here we go uh go back gotta
go back out away here we go dude you
could eat you all right so it's the
shorts it's episode number eight called
Trek Wars is the name of that one so
stick with that you'll see the punchline
that that was used for I watched twice
and I hated it more in the second
viewing Oh last Jedi
yeah that's not encouraging from what I
understand people are saying this movies
racist to Mexicans because the bad guys
are the cartel but I've seen reactions
from actual Mexicans who enjoyed the
movie
um I think Rambo last blood has the
misfortune of timing like I I think and
I don't think it's a PC thing I don't
think it's a politically correct thing
but I think we're in a time right now
where Mex
Mexican and their place in America
specifically is very much at the heart
of a lot of political stuff going on and
whether it intends to or not it's really
difficult for this film or any film to
appear to be casting Mexicans or
especially a group of them in a villain
role and not appear in some way to be
taking sides in the political debate
even if the film itself is not overly
political which again I haven't seen
this Rambo film but historically Rambo
has been
political as a franchise so I don't know
I'm not gonna say whether I think it's
problematic or not because I haven't
seen the thing but we're definitely in a
period in time in which that
specifically is very much at the front
of mine for a lot of folks so I get why
it it could become a sticking point for
some people backing up I meant to say
comic accurate Batman
- maybe pre 50 - but it was just a good
film because I love Batman but the state
of media he has beyond Gotham it is hit
or miss I mean BAM has been adapted so
many times it's been hitting this for a
while uh you know I like Batman 89 but
Batman Returns has some serious problems
and then we get Batman Forever which I'm
a slight apologist for him but then
Batman or Robin Lee you know Batman has
one of the longer and more thorough
adaptation track records but it's it's
far from a solid one yeah and that not
again has nothing to do with with the
current state of the DC movies that's
just there's just a lot of Batman to be
dealing with one thing I missed on the
October list is the good play here truly
evil yeah I haven't and I haven't
started getting to good play stuff yet
and I don't know I said like I'm not
doing episode by episode reviews on the
good place that was never in the cards I
can't I can't fit it in I don't have
time I gotta figure out when the season
ends I'll probably do a wrap-up assuming
I can get caught up by then Trek Wars
how did you write a comedy sketch about
Trek and Star Wars when you've barely
seen Trek don't mean that to sound how
it does actually curious because it's
not a particularly deep comedic
perspective and like I
done more than barely seen track for how
much track there is I've seen an okay
amount like I don't call myself a Star
Trek fan because there's no series of
Star Trek that I've seen every episode
on and most fans will be like oh I've
seen all of them except except
Enterprise goes back with it or whatever
but yeah I've seen every movie I've seen
most of next generation I've seen some
of original series I've seen a little
ds9 I've seen a little Voyager I enjoy
it but like again time and I didn't
because I enjoy it I do have enough of
an understanding of what's there to be
able to play with it at least I think I
do
Superman the movie will always be my
favorite superhero movie I I mean that
movie's fine when I hear people um going
out when I aids one of those ones I'm
kind of like nostalgia goggles but like
legit I've got nostalgia goggles for
movies that I love as well so okay so
Sentinel and this got asked in the
discord as well where can I find your
podcast for your classic who reviews
yeah the classic who reviews that
haven't started going up yet they were
supposed to start going up this past
Friday they're gonna the first episode
is gonna go this Friday
I swear and what it does I will put a
link in the you know on my Twitter and
in the community feed on on YouTube and
and once that I actually start doing
that I will start putting that podcast
link in the description along with
everything else as well so right now
it's not there but I'll get it there
maybe do you think the Star Wars
prequels are underrated it depends on
who you're talking to because I feel
like they've gotten kind of a
reassessment and there's plenty of fans
younger than I am who grew up on the
prequels and loved them now people my
age
older do not like the prequels at all
I'd like to commend you the Sith a bit
but you know different stripes of the
fandom feel differently about the
prequels
so are they underrated no I think on
balance taking and taking the fandom as
a whole
with the different elements and how they
feel about it now I think it evens out
to about where it should be
so anyway theoretically the actual topic
of this upcoming projects here's a peek
to all the crap that I am juggling and
that understand that's not necessarily a
complaint because I do this to myself
knowingly I'm fully aware as I work on
all this stuff that I have other things
and to a certain extent I need I need a
fair number of balls in the air there is
such a thing as me trying to juggle too
much but I do need a fair number of
balls in the air because it's hard for
me to zero in on a single project for
very long and I mean part of that's
probably my ATD but so some of the
things I'm working on obviously the
channel 4 videos a week that is ongoing
I wrote a novel wage is currently and
getting beta read and I'm revising based
on that I'm also working with a
illustrator on so there's that there's
another novel in the same world that is
I don't know like two-thirds done no
more than that probably like 5/6 done
that's almost done as a first draft I've
got another novel that I started writing
which is actually God of all things a
romance novel I'm probably about a third
of the way
into that I have audio stuff that I want
to do I have I have a concept for a
narrative podcast that I've had for ages
that I really want to try and get locked
down within the next couple years and I
the play that I wrote and published I
really want to I have actors where I
know and I really want to bring in to be
able to do that as an audio drama you
know and something that stuff that's
more further down the line but some of
the stuff is stuff I'm actively working
on I've started outlining potentially
follow-up book to skirting gender I have
my burlesque performance that I do still
work in the the 40 hours a week day job
I do and then there's like there's a
bajillion things that like little tiny
bits I had like you know stories that I
started writing that I don't know if
I'll ever come back to because I don't
know where they're going but I have I
have so much dang stuff it's it's freaky
and like I said to some degree I need to
have this many projects because if if
all I was doing was the channel that
would keep me busy but I would start to
feel like I'm just will spending like
I'm on a hamster wheel and I'm not
building towards anything bigger which
is why I'm putting more focus on the
novel right now then I had been
previously but if I were to ever drop
this and try and do just the novel or
like just focus on one big project I
wouldn't be able to keep my eyes on it I
would get antsy if they like I got it I
got to do something else for a little
bit I can't keep doing this every day
so yep I I am a tendency to pile up a
project
and from big to little or like even that
idea that I mentioned about getting some
friends of watchin BBS you know that's
that's on the list any advice on how to
set up your world in a novel um I kind
of feel like you should wait until
mine's published and you get a sense of
whether or not I'm worth taking advice
from oh yeah III don't really know is
like I'm that's one of the things I'm
working on I've realized as I've started
to get feedback that my my weakness is
in overall narration because my strength
is in dialogue and character
interactions so when I have to just sort
of describe stuff going on that's not my
best work that's kind of where I'm
focusing a lot of my revision work right
now do you still have to hide your
breasts at work well I'll back up I've
never had to I chose to I do still wear
a sports bra so they're usually they're
usually a bit more clam down that you're
seeing right now but depending on the
shirt I'm wearing I I don't always um
but usually I still do did you ever
dream of the doctor and if so which is
your doctor you met is it different from
actual faith I probably have but not
that I can remember
I don't retain memory of dreams for very
long I'll wake up and like if someone's
right there I could probably like relay
something immediately but they don't
stick in my head after that the details
fade very quickly and what few remain
usually don't make sense
did you watch Lindsay else's newest
video about Disney's wellness I did i
watch Lindsay Alice's stuff pretty soon
after it comes out because she's she's
really good she's really very very good
at this breathing for a day or two more
soon I cannot fathom menís hold on
alright I can't go I can't quite follow
that comment I have an assigned female
birth friend who used to identify his
male but it's back to identifying as
females making me wonder if LGBT people
can change what would you say well when
it comes to questions of gender
expression in particular yeah I think
anyone's capable of changing I think
there's always a lot of anxiety and
discomfort because nobody likes to feel
like they're reinforcing the notion of
oh it's just a phase because that's
that's something that is used very much
to to dissuade lgbtq+ people from being
who they are but at the same time if who
you are ended up not feeling right in
the direction you went yeah it could
change it for some people it does and
that's true sexuality as well
but I do I do feel like there's a lot
more hang-ups right now around gender
expression than there is about sexuality
so I feel like that that's a little bit
more of a minefield both for people
experiencing gender variances or
questioning their gender and those
trying to understand people like that
even if they themselves are not and it's
so
like the thing is sometimes you don't
know something isn't right for you until
you've tried it and yeah there's
certainly some people where that is the
case for their gender expression or even
their sexuality
if you feel odd about if something feels
like it's not right and you go well let
me try this you try it maybe it's a
little better but it's not right either
you go okay that wasn't it I'll reset to
zero and try something else I mean it
might be a bit of a crass comparison but
you know imagine like you're going God
like something in my diet is not working
so you change your diet to something
else see if that works better maybe does
maybe it doesn't maybe you go back to
what it was maybe you find another
option that's a very odd hang I think I
see in a stream of someone who someone
who follow reacting to nostalgic critics
review of the wall and dear God it
wasn't just a train wreck it was a
spaceship crashing into the freaking Sun
yeah I haven't seen it I don't intend to
see it but that was really weird seeing
nostalgia critic start to trend for this
review of wobble and just watching the
internet lose its mind and basically
everyone decide what a dick
that's again no judgement on my end cuz
I haven't seen it and I'm not gonna
judge the thing that I haven't seen but
wow wow the reactions to that
whoo I don't mean like reactions like
reaction videos again I haven't seen
those either but just like seeing
people's online reactions and seeing a
trending just wow and I I mean I don't
think that's something I ought to watch
anyway cuz I really like the wall the
original like Pink Floyd's the wall so
you know I don't think I really care to
see someone take it apart regardless cuz
it is one of those things like it's not
for everybody and plenty people
don't get it and that's fine and you
know if you if you're gonna try and pull
something apart it should be something
you at least understand and ideally
something that you like because I said
the best critics of something are the
people who love it who are willing to
acknowledge the flaws I couldn't finish
that review was just too I got five
minutes in the review had to shut it off
Wow
do you have any videos you made that you
are particularly proud of um I've got a
few I'm I am really proud of the barrier
gaze trope video there was a video I did
a while back I'm talking about
proportional representation through the
lens of talking about Wonder Woman the
movie I'm really proud of that video
there's there's all those the the one I
did sort of addressing JK roll
JK Rowling and and representation and in
the Harry Potter books I'm proud of that
for how calm I kept given how frustrated
I was I'm very proud of myself for for
keeping that one civil every girl and
boy of every age would you like to see
something is strange come now you will
see in our town of Halloween this is
Halloween this is Halloween not gonna
keep saying cuz I'll get to monitize
curious about this video now I don't
even know what the wall it is okay so DB
well first of all I don't know if you
know who nostalgia critic is Doug Walker
there's a nostalgia critic the YouTube
channel is called channel awesome
he basically just has a thing where he
rips into movies and that's just kind of
what he does and the wall so there's
head the the band Pink Floyd they
released an album and it's a concept
album and they did a touring stage show
called the wall and it's a seminal album
it's a great piece of work
it's very introspective it's very
depressing and there was a film version
made which is very weird like very cool
and I love it but it's weird
it's really weird and so apparently
nostalgia critic did a review of the
wall and he did it as a musical review
where he didn't just talk about the film
he sang about the film parrying doing
parodies of these songs from the film
which seemed to be one more rig I like
the impression I have is that people did
not like what he had to say cuz it felt
very uninformed about what he was
talking about but they really hated the
way he was saying ie singing it how do
you feel about the classic who series
being released as blu-ray collection so
far they've announced series 23 26 -
series 10 I don't really have any
feelings cuz I don't intend to buy the
blu-ray collections III watch classic
who threw brick box and that's good
enough for me I I have no intention to
buy the blu-ray collection story I have
no opinion I hope people who shell out
the money for them enjoy them how can
you have any pudding if you don't eat
your meat stand still laddie
I like Doug's old content like his The
Adventure of Sonic the Hedgehog cartoon
yeah like I haven't talked about channel
awesome in a while because I don't watch
it anymore but you know I
I used to enjoy that stuff but you know
with stuff that came out um you know
when the whole change the channel thing
happened I just I didn't feel
comfortable watching the stuff anymore
and then I realized after having not
watched it for a bit like I took a break
from it figuring that assuming nothing
else went stupid over there that I'd
soften it I'd start watching them again
but then I realized after a while a
while I don't actually miss it all that
much and that was that couldn't get
through the first three minutes of
Doug's review I can't believe I even
liked him that yeah that's her that's a
reaction I've seen a lot of people like
I can't believe I ever thought this guy
was good whoo rest in peace said Barrett
uh yeah I got into your video I got into
your channel because of the video you
did on the comment on the channel
awesome controversy yeah a few new
people did I was surprised how much
though cuz I did too I was surprised how
much those those got watched like way
more than I would have thought it was
and it's really wanted to be because
there were a handful of people who
basically accused me of only talking
about it for the views except the reason
I talked about it I said this in the
video is none of my friends watch
Channel awesome so I had all these
feelings and thoughts and I no one else
to share them with I'm like well heck
with it I'll make a video so I can get
this out of my head and I literally
thought nobody would care a lot of
people watch that I was I'm still
surprised have you watched the curse of
Fenric yet and what's your opinion on
that episode haha that is actually the
first episode I'm going to be reviewing
in the podcast version of classic Doctor
Who reviews so I'm actually halfway
through watching it right now review out
on Friday I swear
I never knew about channel awesome
before the drama but found out that I
follow quite a few former contributors
by accident yeah the there were there
were a lot of people like I knew I'd
like I knew Lindsey Ellis from her newer
stuff and I found out about her
connection to a channel awesome later on
Linkara I'd found before I knew about
Channel awesome there were some that I
found out about like Todd in the shadows
I found after knowing what channel
awesome was I though I think those are
the three that I keep up with I've seen
a few things from some of the other
folks that have been on there but those
are those are the three I actually keep
up with love you t-shirt yes I do enjoy
this I also regret being a Spoony fan
yeah I never got into his stuff it hit
his whole thing had already imploded I
think by the time I had any sense of the
contributors on Channel awesome so I
never had a reason to get into his stuff
I just watched the wall when a college
professor college professor college
professor showed it during a lecture
unfortunately I was one of the few who
appreciated it because your typical
Egyptian viewer prefers simple movie
tropes the wall as many things simple it
is not it is yeah it is not a
straightforward narrative pardon me
ah people or he created the wall as a
reaction to our fans were acting in
their concerts and I was they got bigger
they were in essence not as intimate I
mean we owe the the backstory behind it
is yeah I mean it fits so many blessings
thanks everybody
ah
make sure you've caught up on the
discord oh yeah oh goodness
thank you Karen okay so let me see what
we've got over here so there there was
the question of what's going on with the
classic reviews on the podcast Friday um
oh what am i what am i discord folks as
a picture of em with a dick depart ol oh
I don't know who Chad Johnson is but I
know dick de Borda Bartolo was a writer
for Mad Magazine
he's there he's got a picture with him
he's got a counseling shirt on but not
not dig DeBartolo but the guy I'm in
discord which is very cool ever get to
the point of feeling like your brain is
going to explode for all the things you
have planned need planning etc um yes
and no I feel like my brain is gonna
explode trying to work out the logistics
to everything I planned like the reason
I have so many plans and projects and
things that are started is because they
excite me so like having all the ideas
doesn't overwhelm me committing to
actually seeing them through that can be
overwhelming sometimes
all right think that was all for the
discord not a lot this time which fine
because I mean like I didn't I think I'm
very I don't think I had as much mileage
in the supposed topic this week as as I
thought there was gonna be like I think
I've talked about it like for five
minutes
suppose you just been me answering the
questions what usually happens but
usually I bring it back to something
should I watch the wall first or listen
to the album first um I personally would
say and listen to the album so that you
can have your own experience of it and
then watch the movie after that so that
you can see the specific vision of the
people who made it but I think one of
the really nice things about something
like a concept album is you can listen
to it and have your own experience of it
because it's gonna be very unique to you
however you however it makes you feel
classic a DD oh yeah oh yeah but very
much oh here's an idea
oh here's an idea Oh piece of candy oopy
scandi have you ever seen the video
about the night the 2019 Katz movie
musical Patrick H Williams made an epic
vid
oh yeah I saw that I keep up with his
stuff it was interesting his perspective
on that not sure I share it but it was
interesting to see do you listen to the
bacon and eggs podcast perchance I'm I'm
familiar with it or at least I've heard
of it it's come to my attention through
Twitter I have not it's all my to give a
listen to this I have not gotten to it
yet
and Patrick l8 Williams quite st or
youtuber and reviews I'm not sure what
you mean by s tier I feel like you're
dropping jargon for someone much younger
than me any thoughts on the oh I knew
somebody was gonna ask this eventually
any thoughts on the George Lucan Disney
treason thing okay I know that was gonna
come up sooner or later
so in case anyone didn't know um Bob
Iger who is the outgoing head of Disney
he's been there I guess ten years now
and he's he's still there but he's not
his contracts not getting renewed not
they're not firing him he's choosing to
be done because he's made enough of the
money like all of it so he wrote a book
that he released and about his time at
Disney and one of the things he put in
there was that George Lucas felt very
betrayed by what Disney was doing with
Star Wars now it's a very odd thing that
he even said this because George Lucas
himself hasn't said anything about what
he thinks about the Disney Star Wars so
it's very odd that someone like Bob Iger
would basically put in a book something
that is not corroborated by the by
George Lucas himself it basically makes
MN Disney look like jerks it's very odd
that he did that now granted he's on his
way out he so he doesn't really have a
reason to to wax Disney's car and make
them look good in all instances
the way he would if he if he was looking
to rehab its contract again so it's not
to say that like it it's not completely
unbelievable that he's being honest
about it it's just very odd to me that
he did that and I don't have super
strong feelings about it because George
Lucas himself hasn't said anything now
that's not me being like George we must
know your I mean if you
talk about it's nobody's business but
it's weird for me to even try and have
an opinion on that because I'd be trying
to have an opinion on what one guy said
another guy felt I'm like I have a hard
time getting committed into that but
what I would say is that dang it mess
this up if if I curse account is
accurate then I think it is a shame that
George and then again assuming it's
accurate it's a shame that George may
have been led to believe that he would
be consulted and some of his ideas at
least used this framework when that was
not the case even a little bit and I
also feel like pointing out cuz I've
seen a number of people say this well
like too bad he got the money he's like
what reminder folks he didn't keep the
money he donated the money he didn't
sell Star Wars for the money
he sold Star Wars because not because he
had no ideas left for it but because he
didn't have the drive to see any any
more finished projects on Star Wars so
he he sold it somebody else and then he
donated the money to charity so I don't
know I feel like I want to get more
information from you know from the
people involved but I also feel like if
George Lucas hasn't said up to now then
he probably doesn't want to talk about
it and leave it at that their daddy all
the time wait what what has gone on with
the oh okay okay so someone had asked
I'm actually curious in your daughter
calling you dad or father or first you
gender-neutral terms like parents no as
Kara once said I'm daddy
that's just whatever I'm sorry Caroline
you threw me on because I just saw it
isolation
that their daddy all the time and like
my brain went somewhere else to other
possible interpretations of daddy
I now have made everything very weird
and I'm sorry after the special editions
I'm not sad that Jorge lost the
stewardship just to be honest we're in
an interesting time where enough people
feel negativity towards the Disney stuff
that would they're kind of idolizing
George Lucas a bit which is odd
considering how much George Lucas almost
seemed to be going out of his way to
take off longtime fans some of the time
so you know even if you're someone who
doesn't like the Disney stuff I feel
like most of you within like Disney also
didn't like the prequels and did like
the special editions and like weren't
fans of George Lucas so it's it's funny
to me it's a bit how like now that we
have a new showrunner for a doctor who
now that chip knows there everyone's
going Oh Moffat was so good like you
guys were all shouting about how much he
hated Moffat when he was in charge but
now that he's gone and you've decided
you like the new guy less now he was
brilliant I feel I feel like there's a
little bit of that going on water will
cure the daddy weirdness well hopefully
it'll at least dull the sensation if I'd
seen it in isolation I would have gone
the exact same place oh good so it's not
just me the best starwars
equals Erin Lucas equals Clone Wars so
you haven't seen any of Clone Wars so I
can't say do you plan on covering
missing Doctor Who episodes on the
podcasts COFF Daleks mister playing
cough I'm starting with what's available
on Brit box and as I get through that
because a lot of the many the missing
stuff or things that have had animated
recreations who aren't on there so like
that that
stuff that yes eventually in whatever
form I can get it but like not for a
while the gizmo in the background has an
eyepatch no he doesn't it's just got
Harley Quinn in front of him now that's
that's just that's just his uh that's
just its coloring that's just he's just
got the brown connecting to the patch he
doesn't have an eyepatch does he have
his bow and quiver the the bow made out
of the the paperclip and the rubber band
yep gizmo was John Rambo for one moment
I really like gremlins too that's a
disagreement I have put the number of
friends that like oh grandmas one was
better I'm like you're wrong you're very
wrong which classic doctor are you on
I'm not going I'm not doing it
chronologically I jump around cuz hey
didi um and I have more fun with it that
way anyways you can do that with classic
who because it's not serialized you know
each with with the exception of the key
to time and trial of a Time Lord
you know the each story is
self-contained it doesn't you don't have
to have seen the previous story to know
what the next ones doing gremlins to is
a social commentary on such a deeper
level than the first I'm not sure about
that it's I mean the first one was a
very blatant commentary on suburban
lifestyle whereas the second one is a
very blatant commentary on on high level
like New York style urban living and the
thing is though the second one is also a
live-action Looney Tunes film as far as
I'm concerned so
oh there's one other thing I was gonna
mention before I sign off cuz I'm gonna
do that relatively quickly it's I took
my daughter to see abominable over the
weekend I almost called the Everest
that's what they should have called it
cuz nobody says the word abominable in
the entire movie and that's not to say
that you have to have the movie names
something that they say in the movie but
like that's not a word everyone knows
what it means so to have an unusual word
be the title that you never explain
whatever anyways it was um it was cute
it was inoffensive there was one thing
though that and I mentioned this on
Twitter there's one joke I was really
impressed the lengths they went to to
set up this joke so early on one of the
one of the villains is a guy who who
like was an explorer and was really into
you know he wants he wants to capture
the Yeti because he wants to show that
it exists that he casually he discovered
it you know that sort of thing and
trying to comfort him like his lackeys
we love but you've discovered other
amazing creatures look these rare
whooping snakes these snakes in this
case just like whoop whoop which is just
a silly thing one of the snakes gets out
and like later on like a half hour later
we get a reminder it's just it's just in
the back seat of a car just head pops up
whoop and vanishes again and then a
little bit after that some of his
lackeys are trying to catch this snake
and it's popping up around it's like
whoop there it is whoop there it is
whoop there it is one of them starts
dancing and the others look at him like
really Dave
really and I really cracked up with that
not because it's the most amazing joke
in the world but just they earned that
joke they worked their butts off for
that joke I was super impressed by that
other than that the movie is what it is
more than anything is pretty it's very
visually appealing stories pretty face
in the key to time series the middle
four stories are pretty self-contained
with only the first and last stories
being properly connected that's true I
mean it's a pretty that's a pretty thin
narrative connecting the other ones are
you interested in seeing the new war of
the worlds' trailer was decent no I I
might get to it we'll see also allow me
to quote the doctor new new new new new
version of War of the Worlds so I think
I think we're on a wrap-up
oh and what else watch the birds of prey
trailer that dropped cuz I'm not gonna
do a video on that yeah how much you
tried to steer the taste of your
daughter in movies music etc what was
the biggest pill you had to swallow when
she liked something you didn't I don't
try and steer her interest very much at
all at this point like I tried to get
her to watch Star Wars when she was
younger she got as far as has the droids
in Luke meeting up and then she was like
can we do something else I'm like she's
just not into this
my nephew she's never been interested in
Doctor Who like I'll offer her stuff
like hey do you want to try this and
I'll say what I think she might like
about it but if she goes no I'm not
really like I'm not gonna push it and I
think I mean I think the hard pill to
swallow was her having no interest in
Star Wars that was one more I was like
oh but that was all episode while ago
that was years ago and I mean I did a
video about how the fundamental reason
why she doesn't like a lot of the things
that I do is that she is much more
interested in emotional climax as than
action once but most of the stuff I like
have action climax ISM the problems get
solved with punching she likes stuff
with emotional climaxes and the problems
get solved with characters understanding
each other so you know that's not what
happens in most of the stuff that
that that I really like it I really grew
up on I kinda hope she would get into
but she still like stuff a bit I mean
she likes she likes Batman a little um
she likes Ghostbusters a little she she
doesn't have a strong distaste for the
stuff that I like and as far as stuff
that she likes that I don't I mean you
know nothing that like breaks my heart
that she that she likes it she's gotten
into Pokemon lately that's gonna break
my wallet but that's a whole other
that's a whole other thing looks like a
lot of the kids today are not into Star
Wars well I mean with the Disney ones
they aren't trying to appeal to new
audiences anymore they tried to win back
the old ones which seems to have bitten
them in the butt
my granddaughter's crew left the theater
singing and dancing whoop there it is
two rounds of applause your daughter is
damn mature to like movies like that
good on her yeah I know I'm super proud
of her for that
the trailer was entertaining but it
looks more like a Harley Quinn movie
guest starring birds of prey yeah that's
kind of my issue like whether or not I'm
gonna have any interest in the birds of
prey movie basically is gonna come down
to whether or not I can get over the
fact that it looks like Harley Quinn and
the birds of prey I mean like they did
not end up they didn't go out of their
way to identify any other character in
that thing except for Harley and as
someone who really likes the birds of
prey likes those characters likes that
team it's really frustrating to see them
play second banana in a movie that
ostensibly has their name as the title
yeah but I can get over that maybe I'll
have fun I don't know if I can we'll see
so when Nathaniel turns into a full
supervillain we need to appeal to his
daughter how did you see dark Phoenix I
haven't seen Dark Phoenix yet I need to
I'm going to
oh boy lord help me
well DC drop as a Tanner movie this lady
can cheap a whole horde of enemies
female power much I think that would be
awesome but I doubt it has your daughter
watch Buffy she's a little young for
Buffy I mean like maybe she'd get
something out of it but again it's so
action climax heavy I don't think she'd
have a ton of interest in it
there's also it's it's not meant for
people as young as she is I don't mean
like I'm I'm protecting her from it I
mean it's about teenagers becoming
adults she's eight so you know my
seven-year-old started watching
disenchantment and liked it
disenchantment reviews out Friday video
review for that Rebecca wants your
attention oh ok so sorry Thank You
Caroline I missed that people assume
that gender is a binary concept of male
and female but actually from a
non-binary viewpoint it's more of a
linear spectrum of Ridley wibbly-wobbly
gen D bendy stuff
well said I didn't watch Buffy until I
was 19 just out of pure interest I just
want a new Superman movie already I
don't know if I want that not cuz I
don't like Superman but because like I
need to hear an idea for what they want
to do cuz I don't trust
Warner Brothers to know what to do with
Superman round of applause to Rebecca
yes she's earned it alright so I am
gonna wrap it up folks cuz I've AK I'm
actually actually done for the hiking I
can call it an early evening which I
should do actually like get sleep so
that's a weird weird concept to me
oh well I hope everybody had a good
evening couldn't stay on topic we're
that darn this time which I suppose is
fitting enough going along with all the
projects that I juggle I can't keep
track of keeping things on topic either
Oh Thank You Connor very much have you
ever met Louis love ugh I have not I
haven't been to that many conventions
where he would have been out um and we
don't live anywhere near each other I
don't I'm pretty sure he has no clue who
I am so um you know I the only chance
I'd ever have to meet him would be like
at a convention and I'd I have not been
to that many yeah in a very in that
bigger radius so not as yet I'd like to
he seems like a really cool guy and I
like his work a lot that's the that's
the real name of Linkara in case people
didn't know people are getting excited
for frozen - and I'm like cool but we're
Zootopia - that's a good question
because I feel like Zootopia lent itself
much more to a sequel than frozen did
sleep what's that right no rest for the
wicked
well that explains why I never sleep
okay folks I'm gonna wrap it up so I
hope everybody has a good rest of the
week and thank you for joining me this
this one was was super unfocused but
thanks a lot for stopping in remember
you're beautiful you're valid you are
loved you are the counsel
I'm just running new meetings